bienvenidos a enlace a norteamérica es
un gusto saludarlos desde washington en
esta edición hablaremos sobre el tipo y
la cantidad de ayuda militar que eeuu le
ha enviado a ucrania les contaremos
cuáles han sido los efectos que la
guerra ha tenido en la economía
estadounidense y finalmente abordaremos
cómo se está usando el conflicto como
herramienta política entre republicanos
y demócratas
[Música]
desde que empezó la invasión rusia
ucrania estados unidos ha enviado aquí
1.700 millones es la casa blanca ha
resaltado que washington ha sido el
aliado que más ayuda militar le ha
brindado a ucrania y este apoyo ha
servido también para justificar el
incremento en el presupuesto militar
estadounidense un 4% para el 2023
presupuesto que llegaría a 813 mil
millones de dólares a la fecha ucrania
recibido de eeuu mil cuatrocientos
sistemas de misiles antiaéreos stinger
más de 4600 misiles antitanques abel y
cinco helicópteros
mi-17 tres lanchas patrulleras cuatro
radares contra artillería y contra
drones dos mil armas ligeras anti
blindaje 300 lanzagranadas y municiones
600 escopetas y 600 ametralladoras 5 mil
fusiles mil pistolas 25 mil chalecos
antibalas 25 mil cascos casi 40 millones
de cartuchos de munición para armas
pequeñas y más de un millón de cartuchos
morteros y artillería 70 hammer es y
otros vehículos 6000 sistemas anti
blindaje ate 4 y 7 drones switchblade el
pentágono ha declarado que esta
colaboración la recibí de ucrania en
tiempo es hasta de 48 horas la ayuda
militar ha venido acompañada de ciclos
de sanciones como el bloqueo de las
importaciones del petróleo ruso
restricciones a las instituciones
financieras al gobierno y a oligarcas
cercanos a putin las sanciones han
tenido un efecto colateral para eeuu y
han hecho que los precios del petróleo
hayan subido hasta 130 dólares por
barril en marzo cuando registraban 80
dólares a principio de año volatilidad
en el precio del petróleo que afecta el
bolsillo del estadounidense promedio y
se traduce en un galón de gasolina por
encima de los 4 dólares
el aumento en los precios de la gasolina
la creciente demanda tras la pandemia la
crisis en la cadena de suministro las
políticas monetarias de bailén y el alza
en los precios del trigo derivados de la
imposibilidad de importación desde
ucrania han contribuido
significativamente a la inflación récord
anual del 8.5 que vive eeuu presión
inflacionaria que ha llevado a que la
reserva federal suba sus tasas de
interés en un 0 25% el mes pasado y
planee subirlas hasta un 2% a finales de
año los estadounidenses comienzan a
sufrir los efectos del incremento de
precios está claramente afectado el
precio de la gasolina el precio de la
energía a nivel mundial el precio de la
comida porque sabemos que ucrania
produce mucho trigo a todos alrededor
mío tienen que gastar tanta plata en
gasolina para ir a donde tienen que
llegar que me duelen el corazón yo uso
el carro mucho menos y uso la
calefacción mucho menos también
definitivamente he notado el incremento
de precios en el supermercado pero
afortunadamente no me ha quitado mucho
dinero de mi billetera el apoyo militar
a ucrania y las sanciones a rusia con
apoyo bipartidista en el congreso tanto
republicanos como demócratas que
discrepan en casi todos los temas
nacionales coinciden en cuanto al gasto
militar y la ayuda a ucrania sin embargo
muchos analistas argumentan que tanto
republicanos como demócratas están
usando la guerra como una herramienta
política
desmond lachman da analista senior del
american enterprise institute dice que
con este contexto el panorama político
para los demócratas en las próximas
elecciones legislativas no es muy
positivo
el partido republicano sabe que la
inflación es el problema económico más
preocupante según las encuestas esto es
lo que en realidad le preocupa a la
gente entonces ellos están agrandando el
tema de que la administración de bailén
hizo muy poco para solucionar la
inflación y que de hecho la crear la
gente infecta
defección los republicanos empujan
constantemente al gobierno de bailén a
imponer más sanciones contra rusia de
hecho el senador lindsey graham llegó a
afirmar que se tenía que acabar con la
vida de putin sin embargo ellos son los
primeros en criticar
derivada de las sanciones impuestas a
rusia o calificar como débiles las
posiciones diplomáticas de bailén por su
parte los demócratas han tratado de
financiar otros proyectos sociales
estancados bajo paquetes de ayuda a
favor de ucrania y le ha permitido a
bailén desviar la atención de problemas
nacionales como la inmigración que le
estaban restando crédito político de
cara a las próximas elecciones
muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición de enlace norteamérica desde
washington y los invito a seguir con la
programación de france 24 en español
hasta pronto
[Música]